well you know Keith Vaz Ward is same
what is Leicester City scarf when they
they won the league and I think at the
end of the day you know the the speaker
realizes it was a light-hearted approach
to supporting my team who are Scotland's
Scotland's women who are playing tonight
and the first major championship the
Annie Scotland team women or men have
pleaded for nearly 20 years so we were
talking a lot about gender pay in the
program I mean Wimbledon have equalled
up the prizes but can you ever see a
woman footballer earning water Wayne
Rooney does or a woman golfer earning
what Rory McIlroy does I certainly hope
so and I mean that point the point that
you make about that is very personal
because you've got you know Steph
Houghton I think one of England's top
players or sitting with the high speed
errands about 65,000 a year it's still a
lot of money but we really Erin's few
hundred thousand things ID you know it's
an incredible amount of money but we we
have to be pushing harder there's a
great commercial opportunity there's
agree media opportunity to invest in
women's sport and I think what we need
to see is is more equality in sport the
pay gap being close but also so that
young women and girls growing up have
the opportunity to see a woman playing
on a global stage you know like they
will tonight England playing Scotland
and you know in Scotland we've got a the
number of women and girls playing
football has doubled in the last six
years and that's fantastic news and
testament to you know I'm sure what will
be a fantastic evening a tane of talent
and of course the other big event in
women's sport this week the Women's
Cricket World Cup England have made the
final on Sunday it's going to be at a
sellout at Lord's I mean does it
frustrate you that women's sport doesn't
always get the media coverage it should
do yes it doesn't and congratulations to
England's women cricketers that is a
fantastic result I have to say I am not
like a huge follower of cricket I enjoy
playing at more than I enjoy watching it
but say yeah I mean I think it really is
a frustration because you know what
we've seen with the coverage of things
like you know the Paralympics covered a
job you know tonight that we're going to
see aim you know women's football
covered we've you know the AFL and
Australia as they started a women's
league and it's over
take and main soccer as it's called
there already I mean there's clearly a
huge opportunity for more coverage and
more opportunities to see women playing
at the top level and and the more
coverage it gets the more money it can
generally and the more people can take
part at a grassroots level and I think
that's good for everybody could used to
play with a couple of women who are
playing tonight for Scotland I mean do
they express their frustration to in
terms of things like sponsorship it's
just not there as it is in that in the
extent of the men's game is is it yeah
absolutely so I I plead alongside Leanne
Ross one of Scotland's midfielders the
University of Stirling and against Jim
OFI who is a the Scotland captain who
plead for Edinburgh University at the
time they were always are our big rivals
and both of them have gone on to you
know have incredible careers in football
you know Julie flirting was a big hero
of mine growing up she I think got 116
caps for for Scotland but these you know
these women have what have tough to work
full-time it's kind of like it was back
in the and the d4 like me and rugby you
know the the the rugby players had
full-time jobs and then they went and
played at the same time I mean we need
to move on from that we need you know
women in all sports to be able to if
they're at the top level to be able to
be supported appropriately to get the
right funding to get the right coverage
so that we can we can have your cause
that gender pay gap and just you know
get enjoy as a range of sports and range
of people playing sports and what's your
forecast for tonight well I projected a
draw actually earlier to protect a 2-2
draw but obviously you know I'm
desperate to see Scotland win but
regardless of whether or not the when
it's an incredible achievement to get
there and I know the lionesses all put
on a good show they are all you know
England's have an incredibly strong team
and I'm sure it'll be a fantastic game
and we'll all enjoy it and be chiming in